the dark side
when is it proper to bring out
your dark side
i'll tell you when it's proper
when someone crosses the line
and thinks
they're better than everyone else
tried to make that sound dramatic
okay so i want to address something
i don't know if i'm going to put this
out and fair warning there's probably
going to be some language in this video
so if that's not your thing you're
welcome to skip it or whatever that's
fine with me
yes i made a few somewhat drama videos
about quitting youtube it was from a
very personal place and i was very
honest in those
and most of it was a lot better received
than i thought it would be and you guys
are awesome but i also do believe that
the things we say in general me you
everyone
are a reflection of our inner selves
and you can see
i don't know me trying to analyze myself
which is kind of hard
that i was struggling and it's true i
still am and guess what
so are you so everybody every single
person is struggling even the people who
seem really successful
are struggling
uh with something we all have our
different battles
so
you know the best thing we can do is
just try to be polite to each other and
understanding and support each other
that's what i want to do i want to
support
my fans my friends my family everyone
but you you can't do that because
there's a lot of people so you gotta
kind of pick and choose and do what you
can basically right
well
i guess i'll just get into this
so just to start out
i
think you guys are awesome and
i don't even know how to express it but
it just means a lot but there's
obviously not obviously but there's been
some criticism
that's come back too
that says basically
well i'll just read one of them that's
recent
there have been few very few of these
most people have
been a bit more understanding and like
appreciated basically that i was
honest and not just hiding everything
forever
because
uh that's basically what old me would
have done i would have
pushed this to the side and just been
bitter for years and then
well i'll get to that all right so mr
amen 47 says a basic
bait video and then an explanation come
on dude you're better than that
no i'm not i don't think i'm better than
that i am what i am so just going to get
that out of the way uh it wasn't really
an attempt to be a bait i really just
wanted to let you guys know basically i
get that it sounds very baby and
i have to agree that yeah it kind of is
a bait
but it was also from a very very much a
place of honesty and i've made videos
like that in the past actually a lot of
them but you've never seen them you know
why because i never put them out for
years and years i've been wanting to say
stuff and just be honest and i'm just
not because i don't know why because i
have this
i guess inner ego or something and i've
just decided to let that ego go and say
what i need to say
so i'm not better than that me hiding
that would actually make me worse if i
didn't put out that video
i would be a worse person but you guys
wouldn't know it would just be
internalized in me and it would just
make me
it would just build up and explode at
some point and be even worse so
this is the the best i can do is it
perfect of course not is it ever going
to be of course not that's not how
humanity or humans work
so
basically just doing what i can and
trying to be honest here i i don't want
to watch a guy in his whatevers act like
a teenager
this is just sad
well
i don't take offense to that at all i
think it's actually kind of funny
i don't know what you mean by act like a
teenager
the comment
that he left
is more
teenager-ish
than
my video in my opinion
this is just sad yeah it is a little sad
it is a little sad to
to make videos for this many years and
not be successful and and to eat losses
for this long that that's sad and i put
it out there and yeah it's sad
but that's what i that's what i got to
do to to move on
literally the other option was i
i either put out that video and talk to
you guys about it
or i just stopped because i was
pretty much gonna stop
i didn't see the point in continuing
and uh
i'd rather just reveal the sad state of
things
and be able to like
cope with it basically
than to just ghost everyone and
disappear
i hope that makes sense
i feel like it's the more ethical thing
to do
in the long run
and uh i don't think mr ahman gets it i
don't think he ever will well
that's that's a bit harsh he probably
will at some point
he she i don't i don't know who it is so
i'm not gonna say it's a
yeah
let me just cap this off with a little
quote from bill burr
all right i can't play this whole thing
because well probably we'll get in
trouble but
this 55 out of [ __ ] nowhere it's
literally gonna blow a scarecrow dude
get away from me with your gay little
pumpkin
oh it's brutal dude what are you a [ __ ]
is the reason why guys drop at 55 out of
[ __ ] nowhere it's literally from five
decades it's just suppressing the urge
to like hug a puppy admit a baby's cute
say you want a cookie you just gotta
keep pushing it down like [ __ ] that i'm
not sucking dick i'm not sucking dick
yeah
all right obviously there's a lot of
context here but
basically just suppressing everything
is not good for you and it's pretty well
acknowledged in the medical field and uh
yeah comedians like to rip on it
especially bill burr
because it's kind of true
and that's totally what this comment
reminded me of it's just like nah just
just suppress that move on suck it up
take the loss it's fine
it's not fine i'm not fine and i'm gonna
let you know rather than suppress it so
that's it
uh yeah and also of course you don't
want to you don't have to watch
uh it's not like i'm forcing you to
so
but i'm happy that i got it out there i
feel a lot better
and i'm going to leave it at that